auf und ab wenn sich die lungen so mit
luft füllen dann steigen die
überlebenschancen der chor wird 19
patienten die maschine die die luft
hinein kommt ist so etwas wie hightech
improvisation der in ein startup in
barcelona fragte sich wie man angesichts
der vielen opfer schnell helfen kann
wir sahen dass es in italien viele
probleme mit der atmung gabe besucht
nach einer lösung und fanden diese am
beutel die werden zur beatmung genutzt
werden menschen einen atemstillstand
haben die idee des startups bekam
unterstützung vom autobauer seat der
gerade wegen des virus keine autos baut
auch dort sollten die mitarbeiter nicht
nur zu hause sitzen und dem desaster zu
schauen nach drei tagen produktionsstopp
hier in der fabrik kam uns die idee
etwas für die gesellschaft in spanien zu
tun
14 prototypen in drei wochen zwölf bis
14 stunden arbeiteten techniker und
mediziner täglich an dem notfall
beatmungsgerät die teile dafür kommen
sogar aus dem auto einzelteile die wir
entweder gekauft haben wie wir sowieso
in den autos verwenden wie den
scheibenwischer motor oder eben selbst
hergestellt ohne eine langfristige
anfertigung von werkzeugen bis zu 300
beatmungsgeräte werden im seat werk pro
tag produziert die ersten sind in
spanischen krankenhäusern im einsatz
wir verteilen die beatmungsgeräte an
krankenhäuser in barcelona und madrid
und die ärzte die mit uns in kontakt
stehen dem uns ein sehr positives
feedback
doch nicht alles läuft rund gerade bei
einem teil das zerrt und protoss nicht
selbst herstellen können das aber
entscheidend ist der am beutel noch
schon dann die sind nicht so verfügbar
wie wir dachten wir haben plötzlich auch
eine weltweite nachfrage wir versuchen
das zu lösen und sie irgendwo zu finden
deshalb rufen wir auch alle auf die
vielleicht noch als händler irgendwo
welcher auflage haben wovon wir nichts
wissen
bitte meldet euch bei uns
taktisch werden hier bei der
volkswagen-tochter seat wieder der leon
vom band läuft lebt die idee vom
beatmungsgerät weiter denn längst haben
sich interessenten aus anderen ländern
gemeldet und jeder kann das gerät frei
nachbauen